après le temps du choc et de la douleur
puis de la colère et des incidents qu'il
ya eu encore la nuit dernière à
argenteuil place au recueillement et au
calme pour cette marche blanche
organisée à l'initiative de la famille
de ce jeune motard de 18 ans à sabri
morts le week end dernier dans un
accident de moto et dont les
circonstances restent encore flous de
nombreuses personnes ont répondu
présentes pour honorer la mémoire de
sabri tous avaient un t-shirt avec
l'inscription lumière pour sabri puisque
effectivement cette marche blanche était
est avant tout pour honorer la mémoire
de ce jeune motard de 18 ans mais
également pour a dénoncé l'aggravation
des violences policières qui il y aurait
eu durant le confinement dans les
banlieues omar slaouti l'organisateur de
cette marche blanche chez nous explique
pourquoi cette marche blanche jalaa
symbole particulier c'est un hommage
profond vous y aura un mélange de larmes
d'émotion dépenser à l'endroit de sabri
qui nous a quittés à l'âge de 18 ans
c'est pas pour rien c'est une initiative
qui vient des amis de sabri d'abord
évidemment qui a été porté par la
famille les parents premier lieu sa
soeur donc il y aurait une banderole de
tête avec eux devant et tous et toutes
celles qui veulent se recueillir à
l'endroit de sabri et ce sera donc de
fait une marche silencieuse sans slogan
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
colère à l'intérieur qui a pas
d'amertume qui a pas des goûts qui a pas
de sentiment d'injustice mais là en
l'occurrence ça va être un moment où on
va se poser entre nous
le cortège s'est élancé du lieu de
départ où a eu lieu l'accident jusqu'au
poteau ou et lieu le drame qui se trouve
juste derrière moi de nombreuses
personnalités politiques ont également
pris part à ce cortège pour apporter
leur soutien et leur solidarité à la
famille et aux proches de la victime
coût aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes qui
meurent en croisant le chemin de la
police donc sa famille demande la
justice et la vérité sur ce qui s'est
passé donc on va être dans le
recueillement et le travail de
revendications sur la vérité à la
justice ce qui s'est passé ça viendra
dans un second temps et en tous cas
c'était normal de venir
moi j'habite saint denis on est à côté
et ça aurait pu être un gamin de saint
denis il avait 18 ans donc ça peut être
n'importe quel gamin demain qui par là
or malchance se croiser la route de la
police et décède
j'ai aussi entendu a tout de suite là le
début du cortège des gens qui disaient
dans la joie dans la bonne humeur c'est
c'est aussi j'imagine en mémoire du
jeune sabri voilà venir marcher pour lui
pour son souvenir et puis évidemment
contester un voile à se battre aussi
pour ça ne se reproduise plus est ce
qu'il va y avoir une enquête et on va
savoir si c'est passé mais évidemment il
ya un rapport à la police qui est
compliqué dans les quartiers populaires
il faut il faut que ce rapport là il y
16 fois beaucoup de tristesse et
beaucoup d'émotion en devant ce poteau
qui se trouve derrière moi une minute de
silence a été respectée suivie d'une
minute d'applaudissements à savoir que
toutes les mesures d'hygiène ont été
respectées à la lettre également le port
du masque et la distanciation social
était admise 1 pour que cette marche
blanche ait lieu cet après midi à
argenteuil
autre point à signaler l oea lumière
qu'il faut faire autour de cet accident
puisque une enquête a été ouverte par le
parquet de son côté est la famille du
jeune sabri a porté plainte